okay let me move on to the fifth point
um do women ever get me toot
never okay so let's talk about men
because that's how guys get exploited
so
if you guys aren't familiar with the
concept
there's this thing called me too
hashtag me too i think it started in
2018 was it 2017 2018
what do you think the origin of that was
was that the whole you know grabbing by
the [ __ ] thing that donald trump harvey
weinstein was a star rewind
oh yeah
hollywood's a bunch of perverts and
pedophiles which everyone's known
everyone knows that the casting couch is
if you've watched any sort of prawn i
think we have to say the sensors
intimate films uh at any point in
history everyone knows about the casting
couch that's not a mystery but it's
these these self-righteous liberals are
like oh no we're holier art thou now
there's an issue with it when they're
the ones that have been perpetuating it
since the beginning of filmed
intimacy let's just say that so don't be
a harvey weinstein
yep
it's it's actually been around well
before that it's just that the
weaponization of being able to get
revenge on people instantly via modern
technology it's just come around and
it's the start of cancel culture right
and there it was like a personal level
yeah so no repercussions for false
accusations no repercussions for ruining
the lives i mean the the first the first
thing that i remember when it comes to
this way back the first thing that comes
to mind is the duke lacrosse case back
in
four i want to say i can't remember
exactly but you know quick story these
guys the duke lacrosse team hired a
stripper to come to the party they had
some arguments or they she wasn't
exactly uh what they had asked for a
bargain for
she leaves and then she says three of
them took me into the bathroom and
graped me
and really ruined these kids lives
there's a really great 30 for 30 if you
can find it on espn and there's even
administrators decades later that have
refused to apologize in the face of zero
evidence whatsoever everything came out
all of our claims were demonstrably
false
um
and yet
i mean these kids were platinum these 20
year old kids were plastered
all over national if not international
news
for this without any sort of due process
any sort of um
you know innocent until proven guilty
anything like that so it's been going
around a long it's been going on a long
time but it hasn't really hit the
mainstream into the last couple years
yeah they didn't they didn't really do
something with it until they weaponized
it with the hashtag me too i mean we
really saw what it did with the
kavanaugh sort of you know situation
where this uh
i don't even know what the chick's name
was but you know she's like from 20
years ago or something like that she's
like yeah he touched me inappropriately
a long time ago it's like really you
know like is somebody gonna [ __ ]
accuse jesus now of like you know
something way back in the dark ages or
like
where's the statute of limitations on
this right like generally
nobody can verify
right yeah that particular case nobody
could verify nobody at the party any
people people that she had said she
confided in couldn't remember these
particular exchanges i mean there was
just it was really it was it was word
against work yeah well the hard part
about it is that it got started in that
hollywood scene right with a couple of
people that right had did the d that
most people did but their careers didn't
work out the way that they intended so
now with the buyer's remorse they kind
of go back and blow this whole thing out
and the real tragic part about it is
that the people that are actual you know
victims of actual
of these types of acts right
they're now cast under a certain light
where it's like well all right is this
person just over going and being extreme
going with the flow or is this actually
something legitimate and that's really
like the real casualty in there there's
a ton of cases like and i remember the
rolling stone article that came out
maybe
seven or eight years ago where they did
an entire
huge piece about this woman that was
allegedly raped on i want to say uva's
campus but i can't remember exactly off
the top of my head and it turned and
they published it and they ran with it
and all of a sudden
all false
not a single thing was true and like one
of the most
i'm not gonna say prestigious is rolling
stone but one of the many biggest
publications in the world took this
story as gospel and without any sort of
background check anything like that so
many people are are just ready to print
things for sensationalism and views and
clicks without it
without any sort of research any sort of
look whatever it's it's it's more
important to sell papers than to get the
story right so so two things here guys i
mean one make sure that if you're
dealing with a woman she's got genuine
burning desire that's the third chapter
in my book
when you know she's got it you're in a
lot safer zone than if she doesn't have
it women generally don't meet to
somebody that they're not enthusiastic
about so there's that part second thing
is keep keep evidence keep text messages
sexy photos she sends you don't delete
[ __ ] just keep evidence in case you need
it you never know because apparently
there's no limitation period on this
[ __ ] you know somebody could accuse you
15 20 years down the road so it's like
well it might almost seem absurd that
you got to back up your phone for that
long but you know the more evidence you
have the better it is you're going to
cover your ass i mean if you're going to
be a player you're probably going to you
know expose yourself to some risk so you
have to be careful with that i mean you
will be exploited at some at some point
perhaps right
the crazier the girl is the more you
should save the messages like i have
rich i put in your group i had a color
code like i lead score all my girls um
so the ones that have like a red x
through them means like absolutely under
no
means delete because at some point some
bs could come up in the future lord
knows when and i'm ready to go with the
evidence so that's that's very sound
advice yeah hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you